Hey, congratulations. You've just
learned a new PO trick.
Now what? Your mileage may vary on this,
but personally, I have a fivestep
process that I go through every time I
learn a new PO trick, and I'm sharing it
with you in this video.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, we're getting
down to brass tax as to what I think
your process should be every time you
pick up a new PO trick. But before we
dive in, I just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel.
Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Parer Light Toys,
and Ultraoy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible. You can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. And special
thanks to the non-B business friend of
the channel, Pekka Becklanin. Thank you
so very much for supporting my channel,
my work, and my mission. It's such a
rush picking up new tricks, and I think
a lot of us are really focused on being
able to keep up that rush for as long as
we can. But I think that sometimes we
overlook some ways in which we can
really internalize the new tricks that
we've learned and gain complete mastery
over them in the process. But what does
that process look like and what are the
benefits? I'm so glad you asked. Let's
go ahead and dive in. Step one, find all
the variations.
So, this is not going to come as any
shock to all the tech heads out there,
but anytime you pick up a new trick,
there are bound to be at least a couple
variations that are also a good idea to
explore. Does the trick involve spinning
the pole in a particular direction?
Well, you should probably learn the
trick going the opposite direction as
well. Does the trick involve one hand
being placed above the other? Well, in
that case, you should really learn the
trick with the other hand on top as
well. Does the trick involve performing
something in a particular timing and
direction mode? Well, you should also
learn it in the other timing and
direction modes, too. Basically, this
becomes a recipe for being able to
expand all the things that you already
know how to do and be able to get down a
number of other things in the process,
too. And low key, this is a process that
can take anywhere from a few days to
even a few years depending upon the
difficulty of the trick. Sometimes, when
you have opened up the kinesthetic
awareness of how to make the PO in your
hands move in one particular direction,
getting the other direction down winds
up being a lot harder than you would
think. But I guarantee you the effort is
worth it. Number two, achieve repetition
control.
So for me personally, the entire time
that I've been spinning poi, I have had
a policy in place. Namely, that if I
cannot perform 10 reps of a given trick
back to back without making any
mistakes, I haven't learned the trick
yet. And while I think that's a useful
heristic, I also think it's only the
beginning of the story. See, a lot of us
when we first learn a trick, we're not
exactly unfamiliar with the idea of just
doing rep after rep.
But what if instead we chose to do only
one rep or only
three reps? Is that something that we
can conjure to mind just as easily? When
we put together repetition control, what
we're really doing is we're making it so
that our brains are programmed to be
able to do as many reps of the trick as
we want to at the drop of a hat. And
that makes all the difference between
just drilling out on a trick forever in
a day and then having to stop before
moving to a different trick versus
gaining full fluency over the trick and
being able to switch back and forth at
any possible point. The difference is
full fluency. So once you're able to get
in your 10 reps of a given trick, work
on getting in just five reps and three
reps and one rep and then work your way
back up from 1 to 3 to 5 to 10. Once
again, this may feel like it's kind of
backsliding a little bit. Like, of
course, you could do the trick once when
you first started working on it, but
what this really teaches you to be able
to do is to be able to pull out that
trick whenever you want to and be able
to end it whenever you want to, giving
you full conscious control of the trick
and thus full fluency with it as well.
Number three, volume control.
So, this is a thing that I've been
harping on a lot recently and something
that I think is kind of an underexplored
aspect of learning any new po trick,
which is to try to figure out what is
the range within which you can still
perform that trick, keeping it small as
well as making it huge. So, it came as
something of a shock to me when I
started going back and revisiting old
beginner tricks just how big a range of
motion there was that was possible with
them. Partially, I think this was just
because when I learned these tricks, I
was in such a hurry to move on to the
next stuff. But in coming back and
revisiting these, it's really incredible
just how much potential there is for
making different tricks read in
different ways that we just never touch
because we don't stop to think about,
hey, can I do this in a small space as
well as a big space? There's so much to
unlock here. And quite frankly, I think
that being able to unlock all those
possibilities also unlocks a lot of
performance capabilities as well. And it
does have to be said, not every trick
has a huge range in volume for it. For
example, almost all inverted PO tricks,
as well as tangles and things like
crossers pretty much only work inside of
a small space. But you'd be surprised
how many po tricks there are out there
that have a very very wide number of
variations that you can explore with
volume. I highly recommend you check
them out.
Number four, level control.
So you can think of this as being kind
of a close neighbor of volume control.
Whenever we open up the volume of a
particular trick, we're also exploring
multiple levels with it. But that
doesn't mean that it's also not a good
idea to explore performing a particular
trick up high as well as down low. It's
kind of a bad habit of po spinners in
general that we will start at a given
level and never leave it. Whereas
there's a lot more expressive
capabilities to be found if we are
willing to explore different tricks at
different levels. Of course, this does
mean that we have to get our bodies
engaged a little bit more in doing so.
But in the process of this, we also find
just how much control we actually have
of a given trick and what the potential
is for us to be able to move around in
space with it. I would venture to say
that if performing a butterfly or a
weave up around your head messes it up
for you, I don't know that I would say
that you've gained full fluency with it
yet. So, be willing to explore all these
options with all of your different
tricks. And of course, this winds up
unlocking a lot of other skills, too,
because you can argue that playing
around with behind the head and behind
the back spaces constitute level changes
as well. So, get up high, get down low.
You'll really be surprised by how much
rewarding stuff there is to be found
there. Number five, map out transitions.
So, without a doubt, I think that this
was the thing that I struggled with the
most as I was learning tricks coming up
in the PO world. My flow was really,
really, really stilted for the longest
time because I always treated different
poet tricks as being these individual
islands kind of locked off in space from
each other rather than thinking about
how they could kind of move back and
forth in different ways where I could
build highways between them. I would
venture to say that I was spinning for
probably a good 2 to 3 years before any
of that started to make sense to me and
that's a shame. So, how exactly do you
map out transitions? Well, this is my
approach, and your mileage may vary, but
I find this to be pretty effective.
Whenever I have a given PO trick, I try
to think of there being four points that
it goes through, top, bottom, and off to
the sides, and look to see where the poi
are in each of those positions and which
other PO tricks they might overlap
within them. So, for example, in a
butterfly, I have the moment when they
are straight out to the side. I have the
moment when they're both up top. I have
the moment where they're crossed over
each other. And I have the moment when
they're both pointed down. All of these
are possible transition spots. So, for
example, when the poi are out to the
sides, I could say do a point isolation
stall. I could turn that into a moment
where I go into a flower. Uh, I can take
the moment when they're crossed over
each other and turn that into like a
weave if I want to throw a pendulum in
there. I can take the moment when
they're both up top and switch into a
flower, which I can also do when they're
both on bottom, of course, as well. It
gets a little bit more complicated when
you deal with PO tricks that aren't just
working inside a wall plane here, like
say a three beat weave. Now, once again,
we can look at all those points where
the poi are aligned top and bottom or
out to the sides as possible transition
points. Uh, but I also like to look at
this moment where the hands are crossing
over each other because that is a good
place to go into other PO tricks that
involve having the hands crossed.
There's a lot to explore here. Be
willing to look at all of those
different points in the course of the
move as potentially being a point where
you can get to another move. The biggest
challenge here is not to think of all of
these individual tricks as their own
unique islands, but to think of them as
merely being snapshots that you pass
through in the course of a much longer
motion. It's a great challenge. And of
course, once you map out several
transitions, go ahead and drill those
transitions. Practice doing say like two
or three reps of a particular trick
before you move on to the next trick and
back again. Make sure that you're
really, really comfortable with those
transitions and they feel just as
integrated into your body as the tricks
themselves do. And you're going to see
so much improvement in your flow in the
process. So, I hope you found all those
tips helpful. Do you have a different
process that you go through when you
learn new tricks? Let me know down in
the comments if there are some steps
that I skipped or things that you think
that are important that I didn't cover.
Please make sure to like, share,
comment, and subscribe to help other
people find this video and of course to
help my channel grow.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much
for supporting my channel, my work, and
my mission. And I'm going to depart from
my regularly scripted means of
recruiting people to my Patreon because
there has been a little bit of a change
on the back end for me. Namely, I have
gotten a little frustrated the past few
years with the ways in which the
discovery algorithms on YouTube and
Instagram really limit the kinds of
content that I can create. I have a lot
of things that I want to say about poi
inflow arts and not all of them are
necessarily friendly for a quick little
real or Tik Tok video and not all of
them necessarily are a good fit for
YouTube's search algorithm. So, lacking
other options, what I'm going to start
doing is creating some videos that
feature content that I think is
interesting, but that I don't think are
a good fit for the discovery al
algorithms of social media. And I'm
going to be posting those to my Patreon.
So, if you are interested in checking
out my thoughts on a variety of
different topics, you should go check
out my Patreon and sign up. Access to
all these things starts at the $5 level.
Um, the first video is up right now and
it talks about why I'm not so sure that
thinking of teaching poi in terms of
tricks is always necessarily the best
approach. So, if you want to hear my
thoughts on that, go check out my
Patreon. Uh, I'll go and leave a link to
patreon.com/drexfactorpo
down in the description as well as up in
the cards. Thank you in advance. And if
you're interested in finding out how you
can break out of the doldrums of being a
beginner, I did a video on that a couple
weeks ago that I'll go ahead and link to
down in the description as well as up
here on screen. Thanks so much for
watching. Make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon. Take care now. Peace.